BRINGS US "SEEN AND UNSEEN," BUT
FIRST, JOE’S CARE PACKAGE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANKLE."
TONIGHT WE ARE 15 WEEKS OUT FROM
THE 2020 ELECTION IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE IT, AND THE LAST FEW
DAYS HAVE REVEALED THE
CANDIDATES STARKLY DIFFERENT
APPROACHES TO LEADERSHIP.
NOW EACH ONE HAS TRIED TO
IMPROVE THE STANDING ON THE
ECONOMY AND/OR COVID.
WHEN BIDEN EMERGES FROM HIS
BASEMENT, HE OFTEN SHUFFLES
UPSTAIRS TO A CAMERA NEAREST HIS
FRENCH DOORS WITH BUCOLIC SCENE
FRAMING THE SHOT.
YESTERDAY, HE TRIED TO SHOW US
HE WOULD BE MORE HANDS-ON
REGARDING THE PANDEMIC.
OFFERING NEVER BEFORE HEARD
SOLUTIONS LIKE APPOINT A
COMMANDING COVID OFFICER OR, IN
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES.
OH, WAIT, DIDN’T TRUMP ALREADY
DO THAT?
TRY AGAIN, JOE.
OF COURSE WE KNOW REGARDLESS OF
WHAT HE SAYS, THE ONLY BIG THING
THAT POOR OLD JOE WOULD DO
DIFFERENTLY OR THE LOCKDOWNS.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE WOULD MANDATE
A NATIONAL SHELTER-IN-PLACE
ORDER WHICH, OF COURSE, WOULD
PUSH US TO A SOCIALIST CLIFF AND
OVER TIME WOULD KILL MORE PEOPLE
THAN IT WOULD SAVE.
BUT OF COURSE, HE HAD TO START
HIS ATTEMPT AT RELEVANCY WITH A
SHOT AT THE TRUMP ECONOMY.
>> THIS MAN SIMPLY DOESN’T
UNDERSTAND.
HE CAN’T DEAL WITH THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS WITHOUT SERVING AND
SAVING AND SOLVING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS.
FOR ALL HIS BLUSTER ABOUT HIS
EXPERTISE ON THE ECONOMY, HE IS
UNABLE TO EXPLAIN HOW IT WILL
ACTUALLY HELP WORKING FAMILIES
HIT THE HARDEST.
SPEAK TO MIKE >> IT IS LAUGHABLE
AND IT’S SO EASY HE KEPT THE
ECONOMY AFLOAT BY SIGNING AN
UNPRECEDENTED RELIEF PACKAGE AND
HIS RESISTANCE TO PERMANENT
LOCKDOWNS ACTUALLY HELPED THE
ECONOMY REBOUND FASTER THAN ANY
OF THE SO-CALLED EXPERTS COULD
EVER HAVE IMAGINED.
>> YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO WORK
AS OPPOSED TO FORCE INTO A
POSITION MAKING MORE MONEY THAN
THEY EXPECTED TO MAKE.
THE EMPLOYEES ARE HAVING A HARD
TIME GETTING BACK TO WORK.
WE WERE VERY GENEROUS WITH THEM.
I THINK IT HAS BEEN TREMENDOUSLY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM.
WE ARE IN A PANDEMIC WITH
TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF JOBS.
THAT WAS SOMETHING NOBODY
THOUGHT POSSIBLE.
>> Laura: HE IS RIGHT ABOUT
THAT AND FOR AMERICAN WORKERS
MORE GENEROUS I MIGHT HAVE
LIKED, BUT WE ARE ALREADY SEEING
A RECOVERY OF 4.8 MILLION JOBS
ADDED IN JUNE AFTER 2.7 MILLION
IN MAY.
SO COULD A BIDEN ECONOMY EVER
APPROACHED THAT IN THE MIDDLE OF
A PANDEMIC?
OF COURSE NOT.
WITH NO CREDIBLE PLAN TO CREATE
JOBS, BIDEN COULD ONLY USE THE
EMPHASIZE AND CHEAP APPROACH
WHILE TRASH TALKING SCHOOL
REOPENING PLANS.
>> YOU HAD TO PUT YOUR CAREER ON
HOLD INDEFINITELY, OR YOUR JOB
LOSS, THE CONFUSION, OVER SCHOOL
REOPENING ONLY MAKES THINGS
WORSE.
>> Laura: THE CONFUSION OVER
SCHOOL REOPENING THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN CONSISTENTLY
CONSIDERATE ON THIS.
>> I DON’T -- OPEN UP OUR
SCHOOLS.
CHILDREN HAVE THE LOWEST
FATALITY RISK.
>> ARE YOU COMFORTABLE AND DO
YOU PLAN TO HAVE THEM BACK IN
PERSON AND SCHOOL?
>> I AM COMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
>> Laura: BUT JOE BIDEN’S
POINT ON THIS ARE ALL UNION
TALKING POINTS BASICALLY.
BIDEN WANTS TO UNIONIZE CHILD
CARE AND HOME HEALTH CARE
WORKERS.
HE WANTS TO GIVE THE TEACHERS
UNIONS BASICALLY A STAY-AT-HOME
VACATION AND KEEP ALL THE KIDS
AT HOME.
AND WITH THE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AND THE OTHER WORKERS GETTING
UNIONIZED, HE WILL GET TO FOOT
THAT BILL.
>> THE WAY WE PAY FOR IT IS
ROLLING BACK UNPROTECTED TAX
CUTS WELL OTHERS PAY THEIR TAX
BILLS.
THAT WOULD HAVE UP TO
$775 BILLION OVER TEN YEARS.
>> Laura: THAT IS A LOT OF
UNPRODUCTIVE TAX CUTS.
OF COURSE, BY INVESTMENT
JOE BIDEN MEAN SPENDING.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A FREE
LUNCH OR FREE ELDERCARE OR
CHILD CARE AS NICE AS THAT
SOUNDS.
YOU WILL BE BILLED WITH THE CASH
WITH CRUSHING NEW TAXES WHILE HE
AND HIS CRONIES CREATE A NEW
GOVERNMENT-FUNDED SERIES OF
UNIONS.
ALL CAPTIVE TO THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
BUT DON’T WORRY ABOUT ALL THE
DETAILS.
AFTER ALL, JOE DOESN’T HAVE TO
BECAUSE THE PRESS IS ESSENTIALLY
ACTING AS HIS CAMPAIGN COMES
TEEN.
NOW, WHILE THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF, HE FACES THESE TYPES OF
INQUIRIES.
>> HE PLANS TO DO A NATIONAL
STRATEGY TO HELP US ALL REOPEN
AND REOPEN SAFELY.
>> DO YOU WANT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO JUDGE YOU ON THE
BALLOT IN NOVEMBER BY HOW YOU
HANDLE THIS PANDEMIC?
THREE GOVERNORS TODAY CAME OUT
WITH NEW ORDERS ON A MASS
PERFORMANCE.
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU WISH ALL
THE GOVERNORS WOULD DO?
ARE YOU RESPONSIBLE?
>> Laura: OKAY.
NICE PEOPLE.
BY CONTRAST, THIS WAS BIDEN’S
Q&A SESSION YESTERDAY.
>> THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING YOUR
QUESTIONS AT ANOTHER TIME, BUT
I’M OFF TO ANOTHER EVENT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: I MEAN I DON’T
BOTHER SHOUTING QUESTIONS
ANYMORE.
HE SHUFFLES HIS DAUGHTER OFF OF
THE STAGE, BY BY JOE.
DEVOLVES INTO BROMIDES, WITH ALL
THE ORIGINALITY OF A HALLMARK
CARD.
SPEAK WITH THE IS SUPPOSED TO
CARE, TO LEAD
Speak with the is supposed to
, TO TAKE
care, to lead
RESPONSIBILITY.
TO NEVER GIVE UP.
THAT IS WHAT PRESIDENTS ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO.
>> Laura: IT’S LIKE ONE OF
THOSE CORPORATE POSTERS.
WHILE IT IS NICE, DON’T BE
FOOLED BY THE STUFF HE IS
SELLING.
THIS IS ALL PART OF A CAREFULLY
ORCHESTRATED MASQUERADE.
LOOK AT JOE, HE’S SUCH A SWEET,
OLD MAN AND HE REALLY CARES
ABOUT US.
THIS IS JOE BIDEN’S APATHY,
WHICH PEOPLE BELIEVE IS A REAL
SELLING POINT.
>> WE KNOW BIDEN HAS SYMPATHY,
BUT THIS TIME AROUND HE
CONNECTED POLICY AND APATHY.
HE UNDERSTANDS EMPATHY IS A HUGE
PART OF THIS JOB.
>> WILL YOU COME BACK?
I WILL BE HAPPY TO COME BACK.
I WAS THINKING OF YOU AS
VICE PRESIDENT BUT THEN YOU TOOK
THIS JOB SO WHAT CAN WE DO?
[LAUGHTER]
’S WE WANT YOU KNOW HE WANTED TO
LEAN INTO THAT SHOULDER RUB, BUT
HE GOT CONFUSED.
THIS IS A KIND FACE OF AN
ADMINISTRATION TO RAM THROUGH
CRUSHING REGULATIONS, SPEECH
CODES, NEW TAXES, REPARATIONS,
AND RADICALISM AT EVERY TURN.
MEANWHILE, BIDEN REFUSES TO
SUBJECT HIMSELF TO DIFFICULT
INTERVIEWS EITHER BECAUSE HE’S
INCAPABLE OF ANSWERING TOUGH
QUESTIONS, COGNITIVE DECLINE, OR
HE’S AFRAID MAYBE WE WILL REVEAL
THE TRUTH.
NEXT, HIS PARTY, HE’S BECOME A
LITTLE MORE THAN A PUPPET OF THE
RADICAL LEFT AND BLM.
IT IS A MOVEMENT THAT BELIEVES
THE FOUNDERS WERE EVIL,
CAPITALISM IS EVIL, THE
CONSTITUTION IS EVIL, MOST
AMERICANS ARE RACIST AND THAT IS
EVIL, YOU GET MY DRIFT.
SO WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE
THAT THE ONLY GUY, SWEET, OLD
JOE BIDEN WHO CAN SAVE THOSE
SCUM ARE WE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE
NOW THAT OBAMA, YOU KNOW, HE
WASN’T AS TALENTED AS JOE IS
NOW.
THEY WERE TOGETHER FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
BARACK OBAMA WASN’T REALLY
AUTHENTIC.
HE COULDN’T GET THE JOB DONE.
THE MOST TELLING MOMENT OVER THE
LAST FEW DAYS WAS WHEN BIDEN
INVOKED HIS DAD.
>> HE IS TO HAVE A SAYING, JOEY,
I DON’T EXPECT THE GOVERNMENT TO
SOLVE MY PROBLEMS.
BUT I SURE US HE’LL EXPECT HIM
TO UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM.
>> Laura: THAT IS COMPLETE
NONSENSE.
ALLOW YOU THE FREEDOM TO SOLVE
YOUR OWN PROBLEMS AND MAKE YOUR
OWN WAY.
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN’T
UNDERSTAND ANYTHING.
IT’S NOT A PERSON.
WE HAVE TO SEE THE BITE IN
SYMPATHY ROUTINE FOR WHAT IT IS.
JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE CLAIMS TO
CARE DOESN’T MEAN THEY CAN MAKE
OUR LIVES BETTER OR STRENGTHEN
OUR NATION.
JIMMY CARTER CARED.
LOOK WHERE THAT GOT US.
TIME AND AGAIN, WE SEE BIDEN
WHERE COMPASSION AS FASHION.
BUT THE, YOU KNOW, I CARE STUFF
IS A PREMIER TO DISTRACT HELP
HER LEFTIES HAD TO MOVE ON
ALMOST EVERY MAJOR ISSUE FACING
AMERICA.
AND HE’S EVEN TRYING TO PERFECT
THE SQUAD OF THE RACIAL SMEARS.
>> NO SITTING PRESIDENT HAS EVER
DONE THIS.
NEVER, NEVER, NEVER.
NO REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT HAS EVER
DONE THIS.
NO DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE RACIST AND THEY HAVE
EXISTED AND TRIED TO GET ELECTED
AS PRESIDENT BUT HE’S THE FIRST
ONE THAT HAS.
>> Laura: NUMBER ONE THAT IS
DISGUSTING, NUMBER TWO FALSE AND
DEFAMATORY.
DRUMS SHOULD NOT TOLERATE THIS
AND HE SHOULD CONTINUE TO APPEAL
TO THE BLACK VOTERS ABOUT THE
OUTRIGHT LIES BEING TOLD IN
ORDER TO HOLD THEM BACK.
AND NUMBER THREE, IT IS ALL VERY
IRONIC GIVEN BIDEN HISTORY ON
RHETORIC AND VISIBLE POLICY
FAILURES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP FLASHED BACK
TODAY.
>> WE PASSED CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM, SOMETHING OBAMA AND
BIDEN WERE NOT ABLE TO DO.
WE GIVE OPPORTUNITY CITIES.
WE HAVE THE BEST
AFRICAN-AMERICAN,
HISPANIC-AMERICAN,
ASIAN-AMERICAN, ALMOST EVERY WAS
THE BEST FOR UNEMPLOYMENT.
>> Laura: THAT IS WHAT I CALL
CARING, RESULTS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT REAL
COMPASSION LOOKS LIKE?
OFFERING CRIME-FIGHTING
ASSISTANCE TO THE MOST CRIME ARE
AVERAGE IN AMERICA WHERE WE ARE
LAW ABIDING AMERICANS, MANY ARE
BLACK SUFFERED TWO I’M
PROSECUTED DRUG AND GANG
VIOLENCE.
>> TODAY LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS PLAGUED BY
VIOLENT CRIMES.
>> OPERATION LEGEND, IT IS NOT
TO HARM OR TO HURT.
IT IS TO HELP INVESTIGATE
UNSOLVED MURDERS.
AND WHICH ONE OF THOSE HAPPENS
TO BE ERR INNOCENT 4-YEAR-OLD
SON.
WE HAVE TO TAKE A STAND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SPEAK UP TO HELP
THIS OPERATION.
>> Laura: EVERYONE SHOULD
WATCH THAT "OPERATION LEGEND"
EVENT TODAY.
I WILL TWEET IT OUT LATER.
YOU WILL BE BETTER FOR WATCHING
IT.
BIDEN IS ENGAGED IN A
HIGH-STAKES SHELL GAME.
STOKE AND A FEAR IN THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THE VIRUS AND RACISM THAT
MAYBE NO ONE WILL NOTICE THAT
HE’S A DODDERING FOOL WHO CAN’T
CONTROL THE MOB ON THE STREETS